i'm i'm not making any any comments on
that um
other than you know i've i've i've told
you guys this for the last you know a
couple of years i've always just taken
it one year at a time
and uh and kind of reevaluate each off
season and then
you know find the things i want to get
better at and
move on
drew brees from after the overtime loss
to minnesota on sunday he is a free
agent he turns 41 next week three
straight seasons of
horrendous disappointment walk-off
losses to the vikings the rams and the
vikings again and let's figure out what
the saints need to do moving forward any
talk of sean payton becoming the cowboys
coach ended before it could even start
now that mike mccarthy's the guy in
dallas sean payton's staying put the
question is who's his quarterback going
to be that's the issue that's going to
hover over this franchise brees is an
unrestricted free agent teddy
bridgewater is an unrestricted free
agent and taysom hill is a restricted
free agent and the most you can use on
an rfa is a first round tender and if
somebody out there
decides this is lamar jackson 2.0
will pay him it could be hard for the
saints to keep him around especially if
they have a contract in place febreze
for 2020. yeah that's right i mean i
think that's where the conversation
starts is what to do with drew brees yes
you know that's going to be huge uh you
know you kind of got to figure that out
to figure out what course you want the
rest of your organization to take you
know do i think they need another like
wide receiver on that side of the ball
maybe another ted gin type guy who's
along those you know mold you know he's
getting to the age where his speed is
not as special as it used to be but
i don't know if you really need that guy
if you get drew brees at quarterback
because i don't know if he can
necessarily reach it or you know totally
take advantage of all the times that guy
might be open within the offense running
a go route or a deep post route like we
talked about so that's the deontay
harris can be do you want to already
have deontay harrison he could be that
guy too you're right he could make him
making that guy he could be that guy
that's right so it's not desperate but
the big thing is with drew brees i mean
drew brees is good still he's not great
as we saw the other day you know he's
not making plays for the offense it's if
the play if throws are there and people
are open he's still accurate and can
throw the ball in time and has great
timing and rhythm and all that but like
if sean payton doesn't make the perfect
call or somebody you know breaks through
pass protection can he make a play like
a mahomes or a watson or some of the
other top-tier quarterbacks in football
anymore and go don't worry sean i know
things are broken down i'll figure
something out and make it happen
absolutely not and that's huge in the
nfl and i think that's been a big
problem for the saints in some of these
playoff runs is there's just too much
pressure on sean payton to constantly
deliver the right play in the right
scheme all the time and
not necessarily the quarterback bailing
him out with great play or a great
touchdown throw or whatever it may be to
help the team out that way so i think
that is a huge huge discussion the
saints have to have
we'll eventually know by the middle of
march at the latest what the saints are
going to do at quarterback until then
we'll look for clues here's coach sean
payton talking about one of his options
taysom hill after sunday's game
yeah look he's a good football player he
enjoys playing um
man you know he does a lot of things
well he competes
he had the fake punt actually and
there's just a number of things he
really uh is an asset for
for us he's a great teammate and uh
he made a lot of plays
it is amazing what they have him do and
you know one of the problems chris if
you make taysom hill you're starting
quarterback you lose taysom hill for all
the other stuff that he does that's part
of this analysis no doubt it is because
uh you know that's a tough balance first
off he's not like lamar jackson to where
he's gonna be able to avoid hits and
make people miss all the time he's
different i mean this guy wants to run
you over not run by you so you're
exactly right you lose that aspect of
having the dangerous quarterback run
attack oh we're gonna outnumber you and
all that stuff if taysom hill is the
quarterback yes it's there but you can't
continually beat that drum and go i'll
give it to taysom hill between the
tackles again you know 20 times a game
no way as as as a physical or freak as
he is even he would break down after
that so you're right you know i don't
know if that means you just platoon them
in more next year if drew brees is there
or teddy bridgewater is a quarterback
but really offensively mike i don't know
if you agree or not that's really the
only thing they got to figure out
offensive line great running backs good
you know receivers certainly really good
with jared cook and
of course michael thomas and cameron
meredith and and you mentioned um the
the the punt returner who i'm devonte
harris or dante harris yeah deontay
harris but on defense
that's the next thing they gotta figure
out i would think they're gonna tweak
you know the the secondary a little bit
once again i mean there was corner
issues this year how many weeks did we
come away watching football together on
sunday going saints can't cover anybody
or when the saints have to play
man-to-man they can't do it other than
marshawn lattimore so i would figure
those are some things they got to look
at as well
yeah and you know back to the the
quarterback situation because obviously
it's a pretty big issue pretty big right
yeah and and i mean it really creates a
nightmare scenario potentially if you
guess wrong right like what if you
decide now is the time to move on from
drew brees and he goes somewhere else
what if bruce aaron decides hey between
drew brees and jameis winston give me
drew brees i'll take yes i'll take drew
brees i've worked with ben
roethlisberger i've worked with peyton
manning i've worked with andrew luck
i'll gladly take drew brees those fears
should be gone they should be gone i
mean they only lost with drew brees at
quarterback this year they went
undefeated with teddy bridgewater so
those fears should be out the window the
team the organization should be able to
sit there and go you know what
you know if we had teddy bridgewater at
quarterback we'd probably be in the same
exact spot and i don't mean to knock
that maybe not as good okay maybe not i
don't know but either way what we do
know is he went 5-0 against some really
good teams brees was special that monday
night game against the indianapolis
colts 29 of 30.
he had 116 plus passer rating the
highest of his career and i know that's
an nfl formula that that but it takes
into account completion percentage yards
per attempt touchdown passes
interceptions he had a great great
season statistically yes i know they
lost all their games on his watch but i
i it's not going to be an easy decision
no and and i'm i'm an advocate of going
with taysom hill if you're going to
compare the guy to steve young which
sean payton previously has done
then
then at some point you got you got to
put your money where your mouth is well
yeah and if you think the guy's steve
young you got to give steve young a
chance to play well that's right i mean
you know that's the thing yes you know
you know to what you're saying too like
hey drew brees in the colts game and
some of those again yeah i get it he
maximizes it i you know if teddy
bridgewater or taysom hill were playing
quarterback in that game i think they
have out outrageous stats too maybe
they're not 29 to 30 like brees was
maybe they were 24 of 30 okay
but it might be for more explosive plays
down the field i do think the ceiling
for what taysom hill can be
can make the ceiling higher for the
saints going forward than it is
with uh drew brees right now you know
two things
you know last year the nfc championship
game even though i know they got screwed
over that game should have been over
early the rams were asleep and messing
up and the saints had the short fields
off the turnovers and a good pun return
and everything and you know they were
they had to set up for field goals the
week before that and the eagles game
they kind of took away all the short
passing game two life was hard for the
saints we saw it again last week you
know in this past game life became hard
once he couldn't hit alvin kamara and
michael thomas over the middle like he
usually does once that was taken away
and that's what we saw in a lot of the
losses those throws get taken away and
it's almost like well drew we don't
think you can throw it deep or we don't
think you can throw it outside the
numbers to beat us show us you can do
that and maybe we'll change our defense
and that's to me to where the big
questions sean payton's going to have to
answer because can can he continue to
live life like that with drew brees or
does he want to expand and maybe not
have somebody as quite as efficient but
maybe more dangerous
i'm fascinated by the possibility of
teddy bridgewater and taysom hill yeah
both playing
and i look i thought that's what we're
going to see during that five-game
stretch right when drew brees was
injured i was surprised we didn't see
more taysom hill but i think that that
if there's a way to keep bridgewater and
hill
and say goodbye to drew brees and it's
not going to be easy to do and folks in
new orleans need to start getting their
brains around the idea the people who
aren't the ardent zealous pay attention
to it every day fans the casual new
orleans saints fan who is going to wake
up one day and see the headline that
drew brees is gone you need to start
getting ready for it now yeah cause i
think there's a good chance it's coming
chris yeah no you're right well it
actually see it's weird because i feel
like the patriots fan base is
like further along down the road with
like accepting brady might not be there
then new orleans is with drew brees
right now but that's because of us yeah
i guess because the media has only been
talking about tom brady i think i tried
to spotlight this on sunday morning hey
folks while we're paying attention to
tom brady possibly being done in new
england
this may be drew brees last game in new
orleans too and nobody's saying boo
about it no no you're right it's kind of
flown under the radar there uh without a
doubt but yeah that's the that's the
million-dollar question for the new
orleans saints and uh man i'm glad i
don't have to make that decision i'm not
that's why sean payton gets paid a lot
of money but you know other than that
again the saints are a team that i
expect to be
somewhat similar to what they were this
year again really no matter who's
quarterback i i don't think this team is
going anywhere i think sean payton will
make the proper adjustments on the
defensive side of the ball maybe they
can find another pass rusher you know
for the just in case a davenport or
somebody gets banged up again but you
know for for
for a really good football team they're
not going to fall off earth and they're
not far away and i don't expect them to
go uh too far you know as far as this
austin i think they'll be right back in
the playoff hunt once again next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports